alo alo chào các bạn
các bạn cũng có hai nhóm kiểu nhắn tin
hỏi thêm mình về tài liệu thì chắc là
hôm nay mình sẽ chữa demo một nhóm để mà
các bạn Thể Thao
khi mình còn nhắn lại Hỏi nhầm đấy là có
cho phép mình kiểu đấy ngô nhiều để chữa
các bạn một cách kiểu trực tiếp qua mạng
ngày được không đâu
Xin Chào Ca tài liệu cái gì Các bạn rồi
sẽ xem hết rồi nhau thôi nhưng mà Nhà
mới chưa on ở trả lời chắc là mình cứ
tạm đấy tạm của bạn ấy chữa đi Ừ ừ
tâm sự thì chắc là tôi sẽ tâm sự nhanh
Cái vụ mà offline như các bạn thấy là là
khi mình đã để một loạt cái tát ở đây
thì cái buổi offline ở Sài Gòn sắp tới
thì sẽ là chắc à mình sẽ Lúc đầu định là
miễn phí nhưng mà bây giờ sẽ chắc là mất
phí mất phí ở đây để mà
mua thêm quà cho các bạn cũng như là để
mà chắc chắn là các bạn không đăng ký
cho vui mà người đăng ký miễn phí theo
vui thì đăng ký nó chả lam lắm Bọn mình
cũng phải nắm rõ được số lượng cụ thể để
mà
gì
để mà chuẩn bị về việc là từ để nói
chung là luôn tránh cái tình trạng ở quá
tải đúng không ạ Mình sẽ kiểu để số
lượng một mức nào đó thôi để các bạn
hoàn toàn thể
ở chỗ có một cái chương trình ổn nhất ví
dụ ở Giả sử bây giờ mình có cái hội
trường chỉ chứa được tối đa 300 người mà
không thấy bảo miễn phí rồi đến 1.000
người bởi vì à nhóm của mình rất ở đông
ở riêng ở Sài Gòn Hồ Chí Minh thì sẽ
phải tầm mà
thôi nhớ chính xác con số là hình như là
ba mươi phần trăm đấy đôi khi là lớn hơn
cả Hà Nội cơ đấy ba mươi phần trăm thành
viên của nhóm đấy cư có nhiều loại trừ
còn non đã cả các nick không quan tâm đi
thì nói chung là là ví dụ là
Ờ Ờ bây giờ Nhóm thành viên nhóm là
450.000 người này
chỉ có một phần trăm trong đấy đi là
cũng là 4.000 được
phần nghi là 450 người bước nặn 450 vẫn
tính là quá tải so với hội trường ba
trăm người bảo tôi nên là chúng tôi sẽ
phải kiểu luôn có cái form đăng ký cũng
như là
à Chắc là mất phím tí ngờ mất phí này sẽ
có dư Có quà cho các ông rất nhiều quà
Nghĩa dùng tiền đấy có thể mua quà cả
teabreak cả cái gì đó và lần này có thêm
nhiều nhà tài trợ nữa và hợp tác với bên
xshop nên làm việc chuyên nghiệp nên là
thôi Nghị tôi rất đang rất kỳ vọng vào
vậy là mềm Tôi còn đang phải
màn hơn Tôi không phải là một dân ngồi
thiết kế chương trình nhưng Ý
mình là dân công nghệ mà nhưng mà tôi
phải lên không chương trình xong rồi nhờ
nhờ các bên giúp đỡ để làm cái nội dung
các thứ cũng như là kêu gọi nhà đầu tư
à à nhà tài trợ nghỉ rồi nha Nếu thấy
trợ để mà trợ qua đấy suối tham khảo nội
dung ở các bên giống như các bạn thấy
mình làm ở Tab này mà xem tham khảo các
bên đăng như thế nào thì mình sẽ bắt
chước này à
anh nói chung mà tôi vẫn cảm thấy à ở
buổi ở Hồ Chí Minh này nó sẽ là một buổi
ở chuyên nghiệp nhất và hoàn thiện nhất
từ trước đến nay của định gọi là cũng
nhờ cốt là để mà ở
đi tìm là thể hiện được là thế một thế
mới là một nhóm cộng đồng Hiểu Đông Đông
và ổn ở tại Việt Nam đúng không ạ Mình ở
trên mạng mình rất là ổn rồi ngay là bây
giờ mình sẽ phải làm một cái buổi
offline nó cũng kiểu rất là sự sò các
thứ thứ ổn nữa
ở ngoài đời từ mình cũng
cô đơn nhân vẫn có hướng công nghệ cao
thủ hơn và Vãng thả đấy vẫn chỉ một bước
đệm thôi còn gì À như đã bảo thì sang
năm sẽ là ở Đà Nẵng nữa thì để ở Đà Nẵng
cũng gọi ép shop Nếu mà lần này mà tôi
làm rất là ồn thì sang năm tôi lại nhiều
bên ép xốp để mà hợp tác làm ở bên Đà
Nẵng cũng như là ở Hà Nội phát nữa
còn ở Hải Phòng đấy chứ ở Hải Phòng
không có sốt rồi tính sau
Tôi đang giả Hương ấy thôi
ý bà Nói chung là thằng
à Vì kiểu dáng nào tháng sau sẽ đỡ bận
rộn như thế cũng như vài cái nữa cũng sẽ
ra bận rộn như thế nên là tôi cũng hi
vọng là mấy ông rồi à
ý của làm xong đoán bảo vệ xong thành
công xong rồi tư tưởng thoải mái cho cả
hai điểm kiểu pin nhờ bắt tay vào
chuẩn bị cho buổi offline không
kia nha
Ê thằng kia thì à
em có cả PowerPoint luôn rồi
PowerPoint Word nữa nhà
bảng trong cơ sở sơ đồ thể thao tôi sẽ
xem thử cái thủ thuật Down được
PowerPoint về thôi mở thủ lên xem thế
nào
à à
We are love you more I
Ừ anh đây
có
Ừ ok sơ đồ thể ở
đi
A11 n c trong khối loạn này nhìn trộm
loạn mới được xe luôn chuyện đi chuyến
đi cửa ngay rồi nhà xe nhà xe có nhiều
chuyến đi đánh giá nhà xe không phải là
ngày chuyến đi à
chứ không phải đánh giá theo vé
Ừ ok ờ
anh đi tìm n n a
Ừ tôi sẽ con đấy Mày tên tôi ừ
khi cây bởi vì a trên máy anh không cài
bộ Office không chạy được PowerPoint nên
mở bằng slide ở trên thằng
trên thằng Google
cơ sở liệu
mắt nhỉ ừ
tap21 cái á
em mới một cái là cái tiêu đề xong rồi
một cái thứ cái sau ấy chủ đề Đạt ở 9
rưỡi sau đó hẳn cái sau cả cái ảnh được
để tránh Hiểu nhìn kiểu trong nó bị xiêu
vẹo như thế này
ờ ờ
mà những cái kiểu nó là phạt giống như
là
I my Vision này có thể bỏ đi này giúp ở
đây này ra phải của thằng alt bỏ đi này
language cũng bỏ đi này con fix cả cách
thì có thể để lại này
anh lưu cách tải trong 8 tháng 7
anh cũng đủ
I listen sau đó ơi Bạn ấy phải trình bày
mấy cái này Đấy personal axetic em đã
password reset thì nếu mà bạn muốn để
cấp tính năng này nếu thể để lại
anh nói chung và mấy cái này là mấy cái
phụ mày cái nó không liên quan đến cái
bài toán này kiếm bạn thích thì có thể
tạo hàng cái ảnh riêng mà bà là ngoài ra
em hội trở thêm một vài cái này vào
những cái Pocket của Leo chứ còn bài
toán tổng quan của các bạn làm cái trang
web nhà xe thì ta sẽ chỉ quanh quẩn
những cái bà phải thôi những cái này mấy
bạn có thấy cũng có núi xanh đầu đúng
không bị thật đúng không phải nên à tách
ra làm hai ảnh cái ảnh ảnh chứa toàn bộ
như này xong rồi mình nên mình nên sắp
xếp là nên là
em heo cái luồng luồng xử lý là tiểu lúc
đầu vào như nào như nào thao tác với cái
bảng ghi cho đến tặng gì Vân cái gì này
nhìn nó hơi loạn xạ mà đúng không ạ
Ừ chắc phải nhờ bạn đấy trình bày mình
mới hiểu được khoa này trong gì nó dọn
Má à
cái PowerPoint đấy bây giờ xem thử
a web xem thế nào
hôm
nay các bạn cần phải cân chỉnh kiểu căn
lề 2 bên này à
ờ ờ
Ừ kệ tôi thích Dạo này hết 11 lớn thì
sang trang mới ok rồi này
vì thế kỹ nha Cái này cách khoảng tầm
này
Ừ cái này cách ra lớn hơn hay thừa mục
enter rồi
Ừ vậy thôi không
thì các bạn phải kỹ đấy Đừng có không
không từ tùy tiện cách làm một cái gì đó
có thích bạn này điểm nữa là có dấu chấm
khi mà hết dòng chấm như thế này thì nó
mới chuẩn này
Ok phân tích có vẻ rất ôn đăng ký đăng
nhập lưu mật khẩu Tìm kiếm xem nên tách
hẳn ra từ cái nhỏ nhà rất là ôi
rất nhiều phết nhưng mà chính vì nhiều
như này thành ra mà thành ra là kiểu
chính bạn nhìn vào lúc cậu sẽ bị loạn
các bạn nên phân phân nhỏ lên thêm một
cấp nữa cũng được Nếu giả sử cái này bạn
bị nhiều quá như thế này một ca nó sẽ
liên quan đến tài khoản có liên quan đến
chuyến xe
và những cái khác và những tính năng
khác không được cái chuyện nhỏ ra thì nó
sẽ ổn hơn chứ chứ nhìn này thì cho nó bị
loạn
Âm Nhạc Đúng không
thì các bạn nên chưa thể ở mái nuôi chứ
cho nhỏ nhỏ cấp ta
các bạn sẽ chia nhỏ như kiểu theo theo
dõi theo về kiểu như thế nó sẽ ổn hơn
nhìn này là trong nó dài nhưng mà trong
chính mình nó dài nhưng thấy hiểu nó
trong bị loạn quá
thì các bạn này bị thừa dấu cách hả Giờ
em tôi à
khi sex
à à
ờ ờ mở lớp dạy với thon rồi hiện tại
nhưng chưa phải không có ai trên Bphone
ngoài việc hạn vậy
ở nhà Việt Thảo cũng bật hết không biết
việc Thảo sẽ mở cân nhắc một lớp dạy cái
gì không
đi tạm bỏ qua cái đấy đã phía khách hàng
em sắp xếp lập truyền đi
sắp xếp theo giá Thời gian khởi hành lập
theo Sting loại xe ở vẻ hợp khó ở hợp
music trình tự xử lý hồ bạn ấy hiểu phân
tích rõ ràng phía Lyon những cảnh phía
sau cũng được ổn bởi vì bạn hãy làm ra
suýt nữa
Bắt các sự kiện bon chen tex
xổ số thứ dùng Tại dùng những cái từ
khóa chuyên ngành cũng được Tôi cũng
không bè thì cái đoạn này có api lấy ta
thử thử bác em với offset là số trang ừ
anh Thắng sửa lỗi lỗi trước cái này phải
có cách đúng không
Anh Em Viên method
Ừ cái này sẽ không cần lưu ý đâu Cái này
là cái này hiển nhiên là người cốt phải
biết không không lưu ý mấy cái kiểu về
về kiểu dạng là nên cốt như thế nào
trong ngày
này Cái quý này thì
Anh thường liên quan đến việc mà
lưu ý à Cái nào có
nên để ý cái cụ thể cái nào có sự thứ
chứ không liên quan đến cốt lắm
Ừ thôi không ngoan việc à Chỗ cốt nên
như thế nào làm như thế này à
tiết khá phù hợp để làm tài liệu để cho
bếp đọc có thể hiểu qua được cần phải
như thế nào
Ừ cái này ít giai đáng lẽ phải đầu ra nó
sẽ phải ghi cụ thể nếu mà chuẩn hơn sẽ
phải là trả về dạng Leesin thông báo dữ
liệu như thế nào cũng được nhớ là nếu
như bọn avi chứ không phải là kiểu trả
về view
sai thông báo lỗi trực tiếp kể T
ở đây đây đây cái kiểu lưu ý như này hợp
lý hơn à
khi chúng ta quyết the Faith mà
Ừ cái này thì tùy này này cũng được
Ừ ok
muốn kiểu thống nhất là kiểu cho tất cả
kiểu như này rồi thì không nghe Chắc bạn
dùng Asus crack thể nhảy sáng hành thêm
mới ra không cần inspec ở đây mình có
thống nhất tạm mà mình cứ kiểu enter
xuống dòng à anh em tôi cách ra hiệu
ngày đi Còn nếu không thì giống như bạn
vừa thấy mình chỉ cần sửa cái em tao ở
trên là cầm hộ cái dưới nó sẽ bị lỗi vì
cái xương trang thành ra là
cô nàng ca các bạn sẽ thấy kiểu đầy hết
lên trên và đau Tìm kiếm chuyến đi này
xem tất cả chuyến đi vẫn Khanh thì đi
chị Vân Trang chuyển đĩa
ở bên trong chuyến đi thì không cần nhất
thiết phải à
cái này đi anh đang truyền đi nhanh nó
sẽ bao gồm gồm Xem tất cả chuyến đi mà
he he em tắt mà ra nỏ làm hai ngày tôi
chưa rõ nhưng có vẻ bị tách làm hai bà
phải tính trang
Ừ rồi em mới bắt đầu học của Đức đấu
anh không biết bao giờ mới tới buổi này
á
cho các bạn học tới buổi này thì cũng
gần như là tròn tầm gần một năm đấy
giống như hồi mà mình dẫn đi dạy đấy Nó
là kiểu dạng là
học hết 52 là bắt đầu đi thực tập đầu
năm sẽ học mấy cái mặt của mình nó dậy
lại các bạn học nhau này cũng gần tròn
một năm
nghe vậy ghi rồi nó ra vẫn học trong tư
thế khác Hải Mán không cắm không cao
nhưng ở trường đâu
vì bạn ấy Quốc sự cố tồi này phải ghi ra
nên có vẻ khá chi tiết cũng được
anh được đánh giá cao với cái việc phân
tích này
ví dụ kích phải làm một mình nhiều dữ
thật
mấy cái này chả phải chưa làm cũng có
rồi
300 lưu ý không được để lại cái á cái
này ghi chú của tôi không phải ta ông
ghi lại nó biến hình kỳ tựa đề đâu cái
ghi chú nhé những cái nằm trong ngoặc
nhọn nó ra ghi chú người ông phải xóa đi
chứ không không để lại trong tài liệu
nhé tài liệu bệnh mấy trang bảo xanh như
thế ư
khi tách cái ảnh về vỡ ra làm hai đúng
không và nói chung à hãy nhớ là
Em hãy nhớ đó là gốc như thế nào thì
sport về như thế tránh việc là vuốt một
kiểu qua con một kiểu nghĩa là vuốt các
bạn sửa xong rồi thì các bạn phải cập
nhật lại PowerPoint và ngược lại nếu các
bạn sửa PowerPoint thì các bạn cập nhật
would gái Huế trái nghĩa việc là cái
vuốt này bản thân cái mục đích kể bạn
Quốc là gì
I Mục đích bán pô là gì One word này mục
đích lúc đầu nó sẽ là kiểu với in ra để
cho các
nhờ các thầy cô nếu mà các bạn bảo vệ
trực tiếp nhưng sẽ là in ra để các thầy
cô hãy xem kiểu hình dung được rõ cụ thể
hơn là cái trang web của các bạn đang
muốn làm cái gì tính năng vừa vặn Mọi
thứ là gì đấy vì lúc các bạn trình bày
bằng bằng Powerpoint thì các thầy cô sẽ
đọc đọc bản Word các bạn em xem các bạn
đang thuyết trình Cái gì Vân
hơi bị ngứa mắt mình cái này
ờ ờ
tránh việc áo kiểu các thầy cô khó hiểu
việc nào có tài liệu một kiểu nhưng mà
PowerPoint một kiểu đấy không được đúng
loại các bạn phải thống nhất 2 giờ đấy
và PowerPoint được ra không cần phải
nhiều chữ lắm đúng không mà coi bạn kia
hiện tại nó không chữ tao không biết
đánh giá như mà như con muốn như thế này
thì wadkar đầy đủ càng tốt không Không
có gì Thừa cả mất bạn này thì tính khác
cũng tương đối một cách đầy đủ rồi Tôi
chưa chữa một cách chi tiết hơn chắc để
hôm nay sẽ chữa cụ thể hơn ông đấy không
phải mỗi Tôi mà có thấy cố khác khắp sẵn
không một cô đã có thấy khác sẽ cùng xem
à cùng mình giá rồi Tôi đánh giá sẽ một
kiểu khác với các thời đánh dã là quan
trọng lúc đấy các bạn phần các bạn phản
biện như thế nào sao cho ôn ông ạ
anh Bởi vì tôi dậy có thể cho phong cách
của tôi nhưng mà theo phong cách các
thầy khác thì có thể nó vẫn chưa hợp lý
thì các bạn cũng phải biết nói sao cho
nó gọi dễ nghe thằng thế
muốn nhở thử hỏi các bạn xem như nào
thôi nói chung các bạn cũng phải tự tin
lên luôn nghĩ mình đúng ngày cũng được
hết đi phẳng điện là cả luôn nghĩ mình
đúng
rồi Mình đã chấm cho các bạn xem qua tài
liệu khá là chi tiết và đầy đủ của nhóm
bạn đấy Bạn ấy là một mình
con nhóm nào muốn muốn mình thử xem qua
cũng như là kiểu
Em có thắc mì không đấy nhỉ à
Ừ tôi không nợ lâu không vào cốt với ông
bây giờ cũng chẳng biết là cốt Me ông
bây giờ đang tiến nhìn đâu anh văn như
thế nào rồi
anh em bé rồi bảo vệ được không
em không bảo vệ ở trong thứ 7 này có cho
Thứ 7 này à Thế tạm cho Thứ 7 này chúng
ta tạm nghỉ nhé
Anh Trung Thu cho thua thứ sáu anh sẽ về
trung thu nha nhớ thứ sáu mà
nhưng mà Thứ 7 cho mọi người cùng đi tôi
ra bởi vì thế ông không bảo chấm gì Thôi
cũng không biết à là chị ngày sẽ làm cái
gì Ngoài việc giao lưu ngày nào cũng đã
lưu ý thì ra cả hai cùng chán à
ở trong ngày thứ bảy này mình cứ tạm cho
thằng Nghĩa sau đó thì chốt là thứ bảy
tuần sau đi nhóm vào muốn đăng ký thôi
nhóm và 1 Đăng ký bảo vệ thì thứ Bảy
tuần sau thì có gì nhắn tôi nhá thì thôi
sẽ kiểu chấm kỹ hơn và mình có thể sẽ
bảo bài thử
em giao lưu nhiều vui thật là ra lưu để
tôi cũng không ngại đâu nhưng mà mới
không có bình luận thì thôi tôi thầm như
thằng tự kiểm chứ
ở đâu Đâu có giao lưu với gì
năm 97
ờ ờ
Lạc quan là bây giờ cũng không thể xem
video của tôi rồi còn nhiều lúc cảm thấy
dùng sợ mình kiểu
bị lãng quên rồi Nhiều lúc mình suy nghĩ
rồi à
người
Ừ để mua giúp em công việc IP ngoài môi
trường
công ty đi anh
ý thức Ý bạn ấy chắc là cáo demo khi làm
việc ở các thứ tự đã chắc là để hôm nào
tôi sẽ quay video Hồi nhớ mạng xem sợ
lúc đấy còn lâu còn
anh có thể được nhà chắc là tôi không
thể cho các bạn xem cốt để trên công ty
được rồi nhưng mà tan hoàn nó có like cô
thì các bạn xem qua cách cố của tôi như
thế nào rồi Còn cốt của những người khác
trông như thế nào thì cá nhưng tôi thì ở
Tôi thấy à Tôi
Chúng tôi đã gặp rất nhiều rất nhiều
người cốt theo nhiều kiểu
nó nhiều nhiều người cốt trong rất là
từng Minh Đảng học hỏi trong cậu sáng
sủa thì theo kiểu đúng nghĩa là cặp
anh nhìn dễ hiểu Nhưng có những người cố
tà khá là dối dối ở đây theo kiểu là họ
chỉ làm để nó chạy được Điền hình giống
như hôm qua tôi thấy có một người cứ Tôi
chỉ biết dùng rodger nhưng mà dùng không
dùng đây là quần luôn ạ ạ xong rồi kiểu
cứ thế mới choi dùng b do thôi có thể do
mới-đống bảng với nhau thì người lấy cốt
đeo như kp Thuận ấy tôi thấy mình là cao
lắm chẳng hạn thế à
em có người thì cốt tại chỗ sịn quá à
khi đôi khi ở họ chính họ Ngồi đọc lại
cốt của họ không hiểu đâu vì gặp đấu rất
được tùm lum hết cả lên và không không
biết sửa nhà luôn nó thành một mớ hỗn
độn không biết mấy ông hiểu về sau Quốc
dài mày không có bị thế không nhưng mà
hạn chế Tránh những cái điều đấy nghĩa
là ngay từ lúc này khi mà cốc các bạn
đang nhắn thì các bạn nên trong nó cần
hạn ví các bạn thấy khi mà tôi tưởng nó
chữa cho con các bạn đấy thì tôi cũng
kiểu viết sắp xếp lại cốt Các bạn nhìn
thấy trong nó cậu format lại này xong
rồi Thế sắp xếp lại các bạn nhìn thấy
được nó nó dễ nhìn hơn cũng như về sau
mình sửa thì mình biết à sửa chỗ nào là
được chứ Cốt các bạn đôi khi trồng ngô
rồi em sẽ khó sửa các bạn nên Thứ nhất
là nên cài cái format để mà chị lại được
Code dùng ID thì nó đều hỗ trợ với
format thứ hai là các bạn nên cài KT
score rồi nhưng mà tôi cài hoặc
clockwork để mà ngồi xem được là truy
vấn kiểu của trang web của em làm như
thế nào về mình mình sửa lại mấy câu
chất vấn tối ưu hơn hôm qua nhé Hôm qua
một điều gì nhé Ừ hôm qua tôi vừa viết
cái câu truy vấn nó dài tận hơn 50 dòng
Nó doi4 và chính xác là không nghĩ do
bốn mà mà nó trôi còn lồng lồng nhau đủ
kiểu cơ
Ừ bún cái lồng soi nó là sắc sắt voi
được à là nó sẽ rách bạc con số người
dùng bảng con đấy troai bạn con khác
Xong rồi lại cho vào một cái bảng lớn
cái kiểu thế thế mà tốc độ xử lý của tôi
ờ ờ
33 34 cái bảng đấy Mỗi bảng đều hơn mấy
trăm nghìn là gì nhé Thế mà tốc độ xử lý
của tôi là chỉ có 0,2 giây
ở lại 0,2 giây chạy Xong hết tất cả đúng
đấy thì chứng tỏ là và khi mà tôi dùng x
lên để mà xem câu trên bàn đấy thì nó
đều dùng những Index các thứ và nó kiểu
dạng dặm tối dài cho nên là mọi thứ xử
lý và rất nhanh nhìn bản thân mình nhìn
ngoài cho mọi rồi rồi nhưng xử lý mọi
thứ ra nhanh và
đúng là khi mà mình viết sang dạng
razzil thì trong nó nó cũng hơi hãy chờ
thật nhưng mà
Ừ nhưng mà à
Ừ nhưng mà nó tối ưu các thứ để ý nghĩa
là ngoài việc là về sau ghi có cho chạy
được ông còn làm bài toán tối ưu và làm
tôi yêu sao cho còn dễ nhìn và còn Ừ tối
ưu đôi khi nhiều người không có người
yêu rồi mà còn chậm hơn bởi vì ông thử
cho 4 mảnh cùng một lúc xe ông thấy chậm
không Mỗi bảng 100.000 vay cho mình đi
cái ông đấy chậm không để trăm nghìn đấy
triệu cũng có nhớ đấy
anh ở đây tốc độ xử lý do vẫn phải nhanh
này thường thứ mà vẫn hỏi đưa nhiều vẫn
ra được kết quả đúng gọi nó nhiều người
không biết làm vụ đấy nhiều người cứ lấy
hết sự Ừ toàn bộ dữ liệu của mấy bả với
nhau xong rồi chạy vòng lặp lại mã pin
đã từ hôm trước chính tội làm thế mà
ngồi thì đồ vậy dùng một cái trang web
hiểu ngồi đợi 10 giây nó mới lên anh như
thế ra không làm cái kiểu đấy thì nói
chung ngoài về sau tôi sẽ hướng dẫn các
bạn về tối ưu hơn hoặc gà Các bạn có
thắc mắc gì giống như sinh viên Tôi
thường trùng xuyên gọi tôi mà đang mua
ngay hiện tại đang có hai người đang
nhắn Messenger hỏi thôi nếu tôi trở về
cái tao bay cũng chữa về cố trouser ngay
giờ đây nghĩa là sinh viên vẫn hỏi tôi
rất nhiều và
Anh vào thì nhỏ tôi tôi vẫn thường xuyên
trợ giúp nếu mà khi là tôi đấy tôi hoa
chim xong tôi lại ngồi chữa các bạn đây
Nghĩa
Vì thế nên là kiểu về cốt các dự thứ
không
chứ không phải luôn cho rồi là một kết
hợp được à
cái thứ hai đó là
anh cũng phải gặp đúng người đúng người
đấy là xa nữa đúng người để mình vừa
truyền được cảm hứng cho mình Thứ hai là
là hỗ trợ được mình lúc thời gian đầu để
mình biết được là mình cần phải học thêm
cái gì mình cần phải nâng cao cái gì Cái
thự có những sinh viên của tôi làm việc
3 năm thì bốn năm rồi nhưng mà vẫn còn
hỏi tôi những cái đấy những cái chòi rất
cơ bản này về phía trước đấy toàn gặp
những người ngồi cốc rất là tệ họ còn
phải đi ngồi sửa lại những cái cốt người
ra để chạy được thế nghĩa là phải gặp
Đông những lập trình viên tồi nhưng thì
ra hiểu họ cũng không cong hỏi thấy cái
gì và là quan trọng hơn đó là có
nghề của mình nó khác với nhiều nghề 1
điểm đó là nghề người khác thì người ta
chỉ cần đi làm làm lại những cái thứ mà
họ đã thường thường ngày hay làm
ở gần như thế nếu mà ông mà làm như thế
thì lương của ông sẽ mãi vẫn thể là một
cái việc là là ông sẽ không không hỏi
thêm được cái gì
300 nâng cao được thêm bản thân mình
đánh người mình nó khác điểm là ngày nào
mình cũng làm nhưng mình vẫn phải rảnh
thêm thời gian để tự trau dồi thêm kiến
thức nữa đọc thêm trên diễn đàn vibro
này gì đó chị chai trên mạng nhìn thấy
khóa học cái gì đó để mà mình cải thiện
thêm cái tư duy của mình Mình nghĩ nhiều
hơn mình cốc ít hơn đấy chứ nếu mà mình
Mình không có thời gian để mình ngồi học
hoặc là mình quá lười mình kiểu ngày
ngày mình chỉ lao đầu vào cốt giống như
tôi vừa nói có những bạn cốt 4 năm rồi
nhưng thực ra cái cái cái cốt của bạn ấy
như mới học luôn như cái Junio trong
phải Sino gì cả mang tiền đó là một năm
rồi bởi vì bạn đấy cũng khá là rất là
bận bạn ấy bận thôi chứ bạn nghe nào bạn
ngồi cốt cô thật 89 tiếng khiển không
nói là bạn ấy kiểu là một người của dạng
lừa nhé Rất là chăm nhưng mà các bạn xem
ở đây bạn sắm cốt chưa phải không dám
nghĩ thế bạn kiểu ngồi chỉ ngồi gõ ra
sao cho nó chạy thôi vào tao làm rất
nhiều tính năng nhưng mà tính năng nào
cũng bị chạy rất chậm hoặc là nó ra tạm
bợ so về sau bạn lại phải ngồi sửa lại
chính những cái cốt đấy lại mất thêm một
đống ra nữa anh ra rồi nó một vòng tròn
luẩn quẩn nó kiểu dạng này bạn ấy cũng
không thấy bộ lên được mà cốt vào vẫn
gọi là khác t là như thế
ạ Bạn ấy gặp những cái người đi rước tệ
rồi bà lại Cốt lại cũng là một mớ hỗn
độn thôi Người đi Sao lại ngồi xem lại
lúc đó đây nó vòng tròn đồng quạt méo
hình ông ạ Nên mình đừng như thế này
tôi vẫn đang nhắc mấy ông bởi vì à như
tôi nói đó là mấy mấy ông đang cút nhắn
thì mấy ông còn ngồi tối ưu được hay
ngồi kiểu làm sao đẹp được về sau cốt
của mấy ông người sau dài và khi đến cái
ngưỡng mà ông kiểu
gọi là biết cốt hơn rồi Nhiều người có
cái tôi lắm người ta không muốn sửa cốt
của họ đâu Họ coi họ là cốt đẹp nhất rồi
họ còn chẳng em tham khảo cốt quá ai cả
lúc đấy con rồi nữa để hình như có một
anh tôi quen anh ở rất giỏi toán và mỗi
lần cốt của anh ấy đọc chả hiểu cả Hì hì
hì không đi dạy và anh ấy cũng kiểu cũng
hướng nội ngay cũng trả lại hết kìa
trắng họ ai hỏi anh hãy trả lại thích
được thì bảo ừ nó chạy như này ngay thế
này là không ai muốn động và cuốn anh ấy
đừng đừng như thế đúng không làm thế là
một mình thôi chứ làm dự án thì không
không không làm từ đấy được
à à
chưa ạ
Không mấy câu này thì chắc là mình
Ừ Ừ mình sẽ trả lời cái cái cái này đi
anh không ai hỏi thêm được ok ờ
thì mình sẽ nói qua một tí về cái phần
mềm diệt virus và cụ thể Manuel thì cho
bạn nào chưa biết thì thực ra là hồi
trước mình thôi gọi chung mọi thứ
mã độc mày hay là những cái gì mà khiến
máy mình chậm thôi khiến bánh đô thậm
chí là kiểu bị ạ bị kiểu dạng lại bị
hack này hoặc bị kiểu bị mã hóa toàn bộ
nhiều không không khởi động được máy
hoặc không mở file thì chúng ta thường
gọi chung là virus ra thế sai Gà chuẩn
cái chung nhất thì nó sẽ gọi là Manuel
là mã độc thế còn virus thì nó chỉ ở một
phần của malware virus Nó là cái loại mà
kiểu nó sản sinh ra rất nhanh và nó sẽ
làm tê liệt máy
Anh thường virus nó nói chuyện như thế
các bạn Thể chạy trên mạng cụ thể kiểu
tra trên mạng cụ thể manhwa là gì yếu là
gì Thậm chí còn thêm những có thể loại
nữa là to Dan tất cả kiểu dạng là vì sẽ
cài mình cái con nội gián vào trong máy
khác để mở với sau có thể chiếm quyền
Cảnh Sát hay gì đó kiểm cho Dan bác Đo
này đấy
hoặc là kiểu
gì nhỉ và sour là tất cả khi mà cài nó
vào thì nó sẽ tự động khi cài lỡ chạy
khởi động nó thì nó sẽ tự động mã hóa
toàn bộ file các bạn không mở được này
thì cái phần mềm diệt virus nó hoạt động
như thế nào thường là nó vẫn sẽ chơi trò
là nó là cái thứ mà
ẩm thực sự là không hẳn bảo vệ được các
bạn lắm Nó chỉ bảo vệ một cách tương đối
Thế là sao nó là nó nó liên tục Cập nhật
cái cơ sở dữ liệu của nó là có những cái
loại nào Đăng đang hiện hành và nó sẽ
đoán nó sẽ đọc qua về cái cái mã đại
khái là thế đọc qua cách thức hoạt động
của cái phần mềm mà các bạn sắp chạy đề
mà đoán xem là và nó sẽ chuyển sang xong
cơ sở liệu nó xem à Cái này có có bị đã
bị vào trong danh sách đen Nó chưa được
ngăn chặn nhưng mà có nhờ Hàng Các bạn
thấy là đôi khi nó diệt cả những cái thứ
mà không phải virus chẳng qua nó nghi
ngờ đúng bạn thế Làm thế nào để biết
được nó nghi ngờ thì chỉ đơn giản mấy
cái kia nó có chạy những cái kiểu ngôn
ngữ nó Khi xâm nhập vào quyền Admin nên
là thường nó sẽ chặn trước chứng thực sự
là những phần mềm virus nó không phải là
ở chỗ thần thánh ở đoán được là con nào
có những virus con nào Thấy phần mềm và
phần mềm thực sự là ổn các phần mềm nào
liên quan đến quyền
liên quan đến những cái quyền kiểu đền
amin thì nó cứ chặn hết đấy xong nó sẽ
làm nó theo kiểu diệt trước rồi tính sau
ấy đương nhiên họ sẽ thương hỏi lại các
bạn đã xem các bạn có quyền cho chạy
không Nó đôi khi ở các bạn không quyền
chạy ví dụ những con virus mới tinh ý
thì nó chưa nằm trong cơ sở dữ liệu của
nó chạy Xong rồi bị chết rồi lúc đấy
không biết kiện nha À à
defender thì nó vẫn là nó vẫn là kiểu có
cơ sở điệu rất là ổn ngã ra rộng để mà
đủ chặn một cách tương đối gọi là thường
người ta thường hay nói đó là chạm đến
70 phần trăm các virus đang phổ biến
trên thế giới còn bao nhiêu phần trăm là
lại Đôi khi những kẻ con đấy nó gọi là
Zero đây tức là sao là nó sẽ có thể
ở đây đây những cái con kiểu rêu đây lỗ
hổng sau đây tất cả nó thể chạy bất cứ
lúc nào và không hề
chính hãng ăn mịn chứng này hacker nó
cũng không kiểm soát được là bao giờ nó
chạy và chính người dùng không để ý theo
dõi cho Đột nhiên một ngào đó tự nhiên
Bạn kích hoạt Nó kiểu chạy một cái phần
mềm với đó dính vào người nó
vì nó có lỗ hỏng đấy khiến cho nó bị Nó
kiểu nó máy bạn Bị hack thì nó kiểu gì
đây thì
Ừ thì lúc đấy các bạn chỉ có thể là cài
đặt máy học cái gì gió Hồi trước từng có
người hỏi là nếu mà xử mà em bị thoái cơ
nó mã hóa hết sạch hết mọi thứ thì em
trả tiền nó nó thì có thì có cơ hội để
mà lời dạy hoặc Em không trả tiền nó nó
thì cơ hội là giải mã 01 là đừng có nhận
thường người ta khuyên là không mở lên
trả tiền chứ Khi cực kì cực kì cần thì
gà Thằng hacker nó vẫn còn rất nhiều
kiểu nó vẫn thể không đưa các bạn kia
thì các bạn à các bạn thể lấy lại được
dữ liệu đâu có thể lừa bạn thì thôi hay
là các bạn có thể chịu khó đợi em giận
hàng tháng để mà
có gì mà kiểu có hai đó giải mã rồi đang
lấy mã cho bạn để bạn tải về nhưng mà
cái có rất nhiều con mà đến bây giờ vẫn
chưa giải mã được nhưng cũng không hi
vọng gì mấy cái đấy Nói chung là đừng
Hạn chế đừng có tải mọi thứ ở những cái
trang mạng miễn phí bây giờ nó rất ít để
mấy cái rất ít của nó có hiển nhiên mà
ví dụ là kiểu
download free Download Lac chất sẵn này
cái chả được cái vấn đề này thì ở
các bạn
điều chỉnh các bạn nguy hiểm môi cách
nào để và kiểm tra thì thường à các bạn
Mở chế độ ăn bóp là kiểu hộp khẩu thô
các à săn bóp phải đề mà các bạn chạy
thử những cái phần mềm kia Hoặc là các
bạn không còn chạy thử nó các bạn chỉ
chạy mấy phần mềm đấy ở trong xanh báo
thôi xoa bóp nó sẽ không không tác động
lên cái máy tính thực của các bạn nên
các bạn hoàn toàn thể làm gì làm trong
ngày Mở hẳn phần mềm virus trong này
cũng được sau đó thì tắt xoa bóp đây mọi
thứ đều mất này ra là các bạn cứ chỉ cần
chạy trong này và có như là
anh an tâm rồi để mà các bạn thích làm
gì được đấy tội thường này làm thế đôi
khi vào các trang web nguy hiểm Tôi cũng
thường này vào trong thời xoa bóp đấy
hoặc mở file gì đó có vấn đề đền hình
giống như bạn kia vừa nãy vừa gửi tôi
file Word PowerPoint niệm ạ trong một
vài trường hợp với cái file đấy vẫn thể
dính virus trong đấy nhá không phải
không thì nên mở xoa bóp nhỏ bằng cái
phần mềm
kiểu đại khái tương tự giống gà
vmware thì thì thì sẽ không bị không
không bị sao vậy
anh không cài Office đó thì chỉ đơn giản
mà tôi không thấy cần dùng để tôi không
cài Thôi Cài Sao lại mất công cđv
Nếu gửi lại à
Google miễn phí à
virus nó vẫn sĩ nó không thể ngăn được
hoàn toàn hãy cơ Nếu đặc biệt là nếu mà
hacker chỉ muốn hack mỗi mình vợ thì chả
có phần mềm và virus nào để nhận diện ra
để giúp bạn cả cái gửi hết nó sẽ luôn
cảnh báo nhờ các bạn thường hay bất ngờ
Ly giống như cả bấm và nút là tôi đồng ý
với mọi điều kiện đấy là nó không có tác
dụng gì lắm
vốn hiểu biết gọi là một mức cơ bản của
tôi theo dân lập trình về các phần mềm
rút nó kỹ hơn thì các bạn phải đọc tra
thêm tài liệu có như đấy tính sau nhé ê
chạy nhanh hơn ông nghe thích cơ chết
nếu không còn thắc mắc gì à
da lừa
anh kiếm cophenyl về để mua chưa hiểu
lắm Chồng 15 nói chuyện à
làm gì tiếp theo không ạ Hôm trước mình
có trả lời rồi đó là đầu tiên là cái sau
mình sẽ thỉnh thoảng phải cố tỏ ra vào
tuần thứ bảy chủ nhật gì đó để mà ngồi
livestream kiểu tôi sẽ cốt một cái phần
mềm gì đó một cái tiện ích khi đó thứ
hai đó là cái này rồi cao với 6 sẽ hướng
cửa làm vlog tốt à cái sau tôi sẽ quay
đi giao mà chỉnh sửa đưa nghe sẽ ôm và
chỉnh sửa chứ khó mà quay trực tiếp để
làm khác kiểu nôn em kêu anh dậy đi ạ
Hãy có thể làm Vina cơ cho thứ ba là Ừ
tôi sẽ à Có thể sau khi mà tôi sang bên
FPT dậy thì tôi sẽ có thêm Kế
có kinh nghiệm dạy và cách dạy ở bên đấy
vào tôi sẽ hết ngồi làm lại tài liệu
xong rồi làm lại khóa học sao cho nó
chuyên nghiệp và tôi sẽ còn nhờ file này
mà mày chỉnh sửa video hay là chung quay
Thiệu Trị nhiệt ghi mục lục mọi thứ tha
thứ nói cho tất cả mọi thứ rất là rõ
ràng để tổng hợp thành những cái khóa
học nó kiểu chuẩn hơn về mà bán lại cho
các bạn thể xem và nói chung là nó cũng
sẽ để mà các bạn về sau Nếu các bạn muốn
tra thì sẽ dễ tra hơn và bao gồm cái
việc là thỉnh thoảng tôi sẽ có chia sẻ
vì cái mẹo mẹo cốt hoặc cả mẹo về La với
những cái mà kiểm tra trên mạng thì nó
sẽ không có mấy họ không biết cái tra
nếu tôi muốn xem có ít lắm
anh có nhiều cái mẹo nó gọi là mẹ mày
thịt gà rồi đấy chỉ dành cho yunio chứ
Junior thì có ít tiền đình hôm qua lặng
và tôi ngồi tra tài liệu các thứ nó phải
sang tít tận bên miriam có chứ con nào
trang chủ rosler có như không à
kỹ thuật toán là tôi không chưa thuật
toán để dậy mùi không có rất nhiều trang
sẽ kế toán mà tham khảo mà trang khác
thôi Ờ
chỉ có tuyển trợ giảng không ạ
anh em muốn dậy thì em có dạy ở bên
Vinschool đấy Mọi người vẫn nó quyền
thích cả có người hỗ trợ bên này mà
Mở hộp mai tới offline ở mobile online
kiểu diện sẽ phải cần đăng ký có gì mình
sẽ đăng bài thông báo cụ thể mọi thứ sau
nhé à
tiếp trên web cho người dùng giống thích
tóc nó rẽ hả anh
khi
sụp Cốt về ap dao trực tiếp lên chỗ mụn
cho người dùng
dùng thì đâu phải dùng mỗi react cho
dùng cái gì cũng được
thực tập được chưa ạ
khóa web cơ bản thì các bạn đã thể đi
được tập rồi nhưng mà vẫn còn chưa biết
được mình cần phải làm gì văn học khóa
học xong cái khóa web trân châu này thì
bạn đi làm thừa suốt kể đi làm luôn
ở đây em chưa socola cụ thể của legs
mình Mình định chia sẻ là cậu đây
Ừ mình dậy là mail các bạn vẫn chỉ ở vẫn
thờ ơ ca thực tế là dạy nó không nó
không tính được cho tính ở Bảo bạn theo
lý thuyết mà mình sẽ vẫn dạy ở theo kiểu
loại dạy theo kiểu là các bạn thực hành
hơn bởi vì nếu bạn theo tài liệu chuẩn
của nó thì các bạn sẽ phải hiểu về cái
kiểu ở đây
Ừ nó live show cô chú là socola like
mình trong khi nhầm khi nó sẽ bao gồm
với việc là lúc đầu nó sẽ chạy từ file
nào đầu tiên ở chạy từ cái đất này tôi
chạy đến bút chép để file cad này tôi
tiếp theo nó sẽ thông qua CE này tôi từ
Canon nó sẽ qua mít được cô e chỗ ngồi
xong ngồi kiểu kiểm tra các thứ thứ đúng
ạ sau đó thì nó sẽ qua sợ finder người
ta showbiz khi mà các bạn khơi khai báo
con fix và provider đấy tiếp theo thì nó
mới ngồi đếm rộn rút rút thì đốt thì các
bạn khai báo trong Nokia các thứ lắm rõ
rồi và cuối cùng thì từ dốt mà mình nhảy
cân chúng tôi cái kiểu như thế thì đây
là một vòng
ở một vòng tròn của cái việc là xử lý
xử lý của Alan nóng hoạt động sẽ chạy
qua từng file từ pha như thế nào để mà
các bạn hiểu qua đời mà về sau các bạn
muốn các bạn muốn chỉnh kiểu dạng ngay
từ đầu chặn người dùng thì sẽ ở Mỹ được
que đúng không Rồi tiếp theo là các bạn
muốn muốn chạy cái gì trước trước khi
nhảy sang bên controller thì có thể sẽ
là khai báo ở trong Spear
khai báo trong cô gái đơn này để cưỡng
thế
Kinh tế thì theo mình khuyên là các bạn
chỉ cần biết về ép queo một tí rồi học
ngành gì giờ thì việc động vào dữ liệu
cho có nên các bạn biết rồi axwell và
thêm một tí về cách để một ngồi làm việc
với dữ liệu cũng cả sàng lọc dữ liệu là
quá ổn rồi mà nó cải thiện một tí thứ
duy nữa rồi còn nếu mà các bạn vẫn muốn
học về web thì cứ làm học Wendy thường
thôi Ờ
a cue and và con khóc để buổi sau nói
chung và cần phải để mô về mình cái đấy
sẽ dễ hiểu hơn
anh Michael levitt và Desire burton
đến chúng tôi đến bây giờ vẫn thường hay
loạn rồi đi ra burton đấy là bấm phím p
nó không khắt khe với cái vụ này như
bằng Java đấy thứ nhất thứ hai đó là
đó
chính là đeo nó nó là Facebook nhưng mà
vẫn chỉ là mức tương đối vẫn kiểu hoàn
toàn cho người dùng thích kiểu design
thêm tưởng như thế nào kịp Lisa button
theo như tôi hiểu và tôi thường hay làm
đấy nó sẽ ra kiểu dạng kia
Ừ tôi cũng chưa anh Chị béo là chưa nhỏ
chưa nhỏ tiểu thư mục ra các thứ ấy sau
đó thì
một hàm một hàm chỉ thực hiện một tính
năng nó thì có số ít đấy
còn nếu mấy ông muốn cụ thể hiểu hơn đi
ra 3 tuần và 15 chuyên nghiệp hơn thì
các bạn phải tham khảo trên mạng nhiều
thôi Tôi không cần để cái chuyện đấy lắm
cơ hội tôi vẫn nha
Chúng tôi thiết kế vẫn đang hơi bị loạn
vẫn chưa thực sự là bờ gì tôi cũng chưa
gặp đấy cũng chưa gặp được đúng những
người cốt trước kiểu dạng ạ có một cái
một cái kiểu thiết kế chuẩn về để mà
các em à ôm theo
level thì cũng kiểu chưa trên nhỏ các
thứ thứ rồi gợi ý thôi à Có một cái có
lario kiểu best best with ít thì anh anh
chưa thấy
về cơ bản thì cái cái này một cái khung
chung của lazaro thì mình chỉ ôm theo
cái khung này thôi mà đúng không ạ
những cái fido ô kết này khai báo những
cái Hà Nội chung đấy à
xe vip oct này thì phải ít dùng
em gái tôi tôi ở công ty tôi có một anh
cốt cho tổ chưa dùng em ấy này
Còn micro showbiz thì tôi lại chưa được
động vào
cho tôi có một anh ở trên công ty cũng
kiểu mới Anh ấy bắt ha anh sang làm và
anh ấy trả rất là chuyên nghiệp level
anh ấy ngồi làm mai cô showbiz trọng hay
phết chả bỏ tôi sẽ phải muốn tham khảo
anh đấy ngồi làm lại cả chia những môđun
nhỏ hơn à
rõ xử lý cả Nhiều lúc mình dùng ô bên
mình không rõ mình đang dùng nhưng mà
nhưng mà Đấy mình không biết đôi khi
mình không biết được là mình đang làm
của trận này không à
ở có gần đây có cái vài vụ cái bức khiến
cho không thể thanh toán được hiến cho
là kiểu bây giờ cứ bây giờ bắt buộc và
viết unit test thì khi mà đẩy cút lên
luôn và kiểm tra là còn thanh toán được
hay không ít nhất là như thế trước khi
kiểu cho mất Cốt và nè có viết unit test
các thứ thứ hơn rồi nhưng mà Người viết
wiitech vẫn chưa phải hiện tại không
phải là tôi Mà anh Minh Tuấn
trước mang về về sau đương nhiên là kiểu
gì ai nên viết unit test cho những cái
phần mình đã làm nhưng mà cái phần của
tôi nó khá lằng nhằng cậu nó phải đẩy
hẳn sang avi còn được bên thứ 3 đây là
khó một việc uống nước test được
ở chỗ đẩy sang để mà kiểm tra xem mà nó
khớp dữ liệu nó không nó lại là câu
chuyện khác
ngoài kỷ niệm lại UV
có những cái những cái về cấu trúc về
sau hay những cái mẹo về sau hả Tối ưu
như nào cậu cách Cốt nó như nào thì tôi
sẽ luôn tham khảo cập nhật các thứ thứ
tôi tôi có tính ham học mà tôi sẽ có gì
để tôi sẽ ở lại Cốt và các bạn sẽ để
cũng phải lên tinh ý để ý xem cái cốt
của tôi thứ hai tổ chức như thế nào nữa
Tại sao tự nhiên anh hôm nay em tôi ở
đoạn này Tại sao anh đấy không biết hết
vào trong cái file này mà nhớ chẳng cái
kia kiểu cơ Thế thì sẽ hình dung được
hơn cách cốt Tôi vẫn tự tin là tôi không
gọi là biết coleridge mày nhiều người có
nhiều người còn chưa biết được toàn bộ
tất cả 2 máy hoặc không không thèm Tìm
hiểu về những thế hàm đấy Yêu cầu là
họ lười hoặc họ chuyển giản là không
nghĩ đến thì thôi Tôi ví dụ Bởi vì tôi
tự tin như thế của vì à Tôi tìm hiểu ra
sau những kẻ anh ở trên công ty như anh
để kỷ niệm nhiều năm hơn nhưng mà còn
rất nhiều hàm rural Ừ hỏi tôi và cách
đấy đại khái như thế thì tôi vẫn cảm
thấy mình còn trẻ thì mình vẫn còn học
hỏi được thêm và con trọng là tôi học
hỏi xong tôi sẽ thỉnh thoảng chia sẻ lại
như các bạn sau nhé
Em in the face và áp suất hàn quốc
interphase tôi chưa dùng nhưng mà tôi
dùng áp sát rồi thì ra tôi cũng thường
Hồi đấy tôi phải ngồi tra xem in the
face shop khác với nhau à
Xin chào hôm ào sẽ thử ví dụ các bạn về
cái vụ internet check tk thì cái có
nhiều cái cái hồi mà tôi làm cái e cái
thì Xuka đến bây giờ tôi vẫn đang dùng
nhưng mà tôi thực ra tôi chẳng cần phải
hiểu lý thuyết đó lắm mà tôi cư về xong
rồi tôi à Hư gọi là hơi làm mò một tí
cho càng làm gì nó càng hiểu được nó
thêm chưa đôi ở để mà hỏi lý thuyết thì
thì ca chai trên mạng có rất nhiều kiểu
thế các bạn phải cứ ôm thử về làm thử
thì các bạn mới A nó là thế này đôi khi
học cái ngành này đâu thì phải thực hành
trước rồi hiểu hiểu nó sau
đó của mình lên xem cách nào vừa làm vừa
vừa nhắn không cũng đúng rồi đầu tôi
nghĩ thế bởi đầu tuổi làm Thế còn bây
giờ thì thôi vẫn làm ra đường cái ngưỡng
mà mình biết cốt rồi không cần này ngồi
Cậu xem cái thứ thì và mình cũng nhớ của
Pháp nóng mình tra thôi Còn bây giờ thì
ở ở
Ừ
tôi không quan trọng về quốc ngàn dài
nữa cũng chọn kiểu nhìn tương minh dễ
hiểu còn là
Ừ nhưng mà đâu nhà thỉnh thoảng mình
nhìn lại cốt cũ của mình bị thế cốt cũ
mình có nhiều vấn đề thật Mình muốn đắp
đi xe lại nhiều lắm
ừ ừ
khái niệm quan cái khái niệm về tối ưu
nó đôi khi nó bị mâu thuẫn với cả cái á
dễ nhìn dễ Đọc cốt bởi vì à Giống như
vậy tôi nói kiểu Nếu mà giờ sự là kiểu
có thể chơi trò level xong rồi dùng một
đồng Viagra cheap của nó để mà lấy mọi
thứ ra
Ừ ừ thì Cốt nó phải dễ đọc đấy nhưng mà
nó sẽ rất nặng vì à Nó que in tận rất
nhiều các thứ thứ nó không dùng cho mà
thằng AK Wen thì nói chuyên nó tôi yêu
nhất ở bên cho chẳng hạn thế
Ừ thì nhiều lúc và các bạn sẽ phải sửa
cái code đấy biến anh coi cái sẽ chọn
Chị à còn phải chia nhỏ hơn nữa là dùng
cho sắt tất cả kiểu chia cái bảng kia
thành bà con đã mình sẽ que hết để cho
khiến nó hình bảng con đã xong mình mới
mình mới do nó thì nó sẽ ổn hơn tôi sẽ
thử ví dụ thì cho các bạn dễ hình dung
nhé nhé nhé
khi
đôi khi có phải ví dụ đã sẽ dễ hình dung
hơn hiệu hơn đây là sử là sự nhé đây tôi
có u ra ngay nó ngoại Giờ này có bài
đăng ngay đúng không ạ ạ ạ
tôi muốn lấy tất cả user và kèm theo
toàn bộ bài đăng của nó của họ đối ngoại
tôi sẽ là select Sao con ngu dơ Đúng
Trước nét do bởi lấy tất cả user mà đúng
không
post Được
on post chấm ozid bằng
user.id đúng chứ nếu mà làm như thế này
thì sẽ ra đơn giản rồi họ chẳng có gì
tối yêu đây cả Nhưng bây giờ tôi có thêm
những cái điều kiện khác ví dụ Giả sử
Bây giờ tôi muốn là u dơ mà những kẻ ozo
Tôi chỉ muốn lấy ra là kiểu nó không
biết thực chất nó khác nút được ạ ấy thì
tôi phải làm ra xử Bà của tôi giờ từ các
mỗi 11 cột 11 bản ghi rồi bản này 81
bằng ghi cho tôi là hết được nhanh không
à Tôi đang nói tôi muốn tối rồi hả cậu
để mà về sau cái u ra ở đây 11 triệu
người dùng sau đây 11 triệu bảng ghi là
sự thế sao ạ Hình thưc À đây cái ngưỡng
trên 10 triệu thì tội cả các nhãn không
dùng empower nữa giả sử dụng vẫn dùng
thì nó sẽ là như thế này nó sẽ là cặp
Thế là sướng vỡ một lấy hết cột của B
News thì mình sẽ là Starex
à à
Nhưng mà mình sẽ
300 kế That
is not known chết sau đó mình sẽ đặt tên
cái thằng này không cho tên là thì cái
tắt của ngay tôi sẽ ngồi ưu
thế này với thằng ngay cho sẽ kiểu Tát
và nhìn ông dễ nhìn hơn khi bạn rất hay
là gì Thằng này đó là tôi đã tôi sẽ lách
từ cái thằng ngu dơ để tạo ra một thằng
mặc con bằng con này sẽ có ít dữ liệu
hơn bằng Urê bình thường vì nó đã lọc
thêm một ít rồi trước khi nào e vừa
thằng ngày tương tự thế thậm chí đến
thằng post này tôi cũng thể cậu chưa nhỏ
ra được nữa bóp này tôi thể chữ nhỏ ra
giúp cho cậu sẽ que không có điều kiện
gì đó tôi sẽ lại chia nhỏ nó ra tiếp
em copy cái này đổi cái này này sẽ post
luôn chứ
Ừ
tôi có thể đổi nó ví dụ là
status chỉ là một thôi
vì vậy tức là sao nghĩa loại này tao vừa
chưa nhỏ cả douzo trước khi do và tôi
vừa chia nhỏ bài post trước khi cho vào
khi do vào như thế này thì thằng ngày
giỗ thằng ngày đưa nó sẽ còn ít hơn phải
còn ít hơn việc cho nó sẽ tối ưu hơn sau
đó thì mình sẽ on rỡ trên nhà mình lấy
ra vẫn nó ra kết quả thôi
ở đây
Đúng rồi à
sẽ rất là nhanh như này có thể tốc độ Nó
gần như không có gì cả một phần này Vậy
tôi ít dữ liệu nhưng mà nếu có tôi nhiều
dữ liệu lên đến một triệu thì nó vẫn
nhanh mọi việc Thứ nhất là nếu mà giả sử
cái đây để đánh nách rồi Cái này thưa để
đánh Iraq nó không vô nghĩa bởi vì nó
nun thì thấy như đánh không nghĩa gì cả
nhưng mà đại khái thì
anh à Nếu mà nữa nó luôn thì tôi cái
khát kiểu để mà thay vì kiểm tra So sánh
nó với nó kiểm tra cách khác nhưng mà
tại khá nói như thế
Ừ rồi hay Safari như này à cách viết để
mà cho coi cái
à Sorry như này thì nó sẽ chứ sao à
à à
ra thằng level nó không hỗ trợ hay Hằng
cùng ở sắt để mà cho vào với nhau nhưng
ai thằng nào thì tôi chưa xem được cách
viết của nó nó thương ai có một thằng nó
cho em một sắc khác thì nó sẽ kiểu Ở
tối với xe thủ viết câu hình dung hơn
thằng Lân là chỗ hỗ trợ là kiểu hai
thằng nó cũng là sắp rồi cho vào với
nhau đâu mà
em nói chị mới hỗ trợ là một thằng cho
thằng sắp trở lại thôi câu sinh vật nó
sẽ nha bây đúng không
Mình sẽ có đầu tiên này giả sửa Tôi thấy
phải post nó nhiều hơn thằng ngu giờ này
Tôi này sẽ biến nó thành sắc trước đã
rồi tôi dùng ngủ rồi rồi thế này nhá thì
nó sẽ đúng kiểu dạng là
cho dầu ngày đúng không
cái nữa là giờ chấm
a
Lê Ngọc có phải đã nó Anh thường là tôi
sẽ báo trước đó là post như thế này bằng
posts
a pris à
cho tôi sẽ que sao tất cả một đúng chứ
xe tải mà đây sẽ là câu Paris của tôi và
bây giờ trong việc này thôi led cho anh
về cái câu cái này sẽ led cho sắp đi này
sau đó thì
gọi câu truy vấn thời tiếp theo là gọi
đặt tên cho nó sẽ đặt tên nó là p sau đó
thì mình sẽ có phong mình sẽ có núi bạn
sẽ nối là từ
khi nối với
Ê thằng Giờ này mình sẽ là other
sợ mai đi cái xong sau đó thì mình có
thể khoe tiếp cái này là que
Anh ngủ giờ
em có bị này nha à
lót luôn như này đúng hàm plaisir theo
sau
đó mình sẽ ghét lấy toàn bộ về ok chưa
để cách viết của việc là ông sẽ thấy
bóng cái sắc trước sau đó thì ông cho
rồi Cái sắc đấy Đặt tên Adidas cho nó là
kiểu dạng như này sống do theo cột như
nào thì nó sẽ như thế này đấy
có lợi thế khi lưu reason vào trong dp
thực tế là thằng ezio nó có bây giờ nó
có hỗ trợ lưu di dân ở trong bê nhưng mà
cũng không Tối yêu lắm mà vừa were dùng
cái thứ thứ theo nó hơi khó ấy Tôi chưa
rõ về con rồi thì như bánh Index cả đây
không được vì nó theo kiểu dạng giống
như Attack
nên là cũng trong một vài trường hợp với
cân mới kiểu hạn Hữu nội Thì mới lưu
dạng dừng ở trong trong d b
a where were di dân của nó có có bfr có
hỗ trợ hàm với theo dõi sự nhưng nó là
nhóm mà không tổ You Do
à à Về và nó sai mà mặt thiết kế đại cấu
trúc cơ sở rượu nữa vì cấu trúc cơ sở
liệu hồi trước phân tích thì một cột
bằng em phải đạt đơn chị không phải giá
trị
à Tôi đang dùng lắp đeo thôi tối vẫn
thích đeo dù ở thực sự được cả vợ bây
giờ vẫn dùng gọi tạm ổn
nay kết hợp đấy nhá và Chắc là thứ Bảy
thì chúng mình tạm nghỉ
Ừ thôi vừa không biết Hỏi gì trả cũng để
cho bạn nghỉ nghiệm nghỉ ngơi các bạn
muốn làm tiếp đồ ăn có nhóm nào thắc mắc
thì sẽ với nhắn tin hỏi riêng tôi ngồi
làm tiếp đồ ăn các thứ thôi nhé à
không tham ăn Sao bảo hôm nay mình kết
thúc thôi chào bạn nhé